bonjour Messieurs mes chers collègues
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs
notre commission d'enquête poursuit
aujourd'hui la direction poursuit
aujourd'hui c'est auditions
et nous entendons aujourd'hui la
Direction Générale des Entreprises
didierge
depuis le début nos travaux nous
auditions nous ont conduit à examiner la
production de médicaments sous l'angle
de la santé publique et du risque de
pénurie de médicaments et c'est là la
raison d'être de notre commission
d'enquête mais nombre des personnes que
nous avons auditionnées et notamment les
industriels du médicament ont soulevé
des arguments et des considérations
d'ordre économique ou de politique
industrielle de souveraineté je pense
par exemple au moteur des
délocalisations passées les enjeux de
compétitivité coût du secteur
pharmaceutique européen par rapport aux
productions asiatiques je pense aussi
aux interrogations relatives à la
viabilité du modèle économique de
conception et de production du
médicament
notamment ce qui concerne les forêts
importants du R&D ou encore la
régulation des prix de vente des
médicaments
enfin nous avons aussi beaucoup évoqué
les projets émergents de rapatriement de
capacités de production en France et en
Europe pour réduire nos dépendances et
assurer notre approvisionnement
c'est donc pour examiner aujourd'hui les
enjeux du médicament sous l'angle de la
politique industrielle que nous avons
souhaité entendre la Direction Générale
des Entreprises administration centrale
chargée du développement des entreprises
et des secteurs économiques je ne doute
pas qu'avec la nouvelle dénomination du
ministère d'économie des finances et de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique à l'issue de la crise covid
l'action de la DGE vis-à-vis de
l'industrie pharmaceutique a pris une
toute autre ampleur et que ce que nous
interlocuteurs interlocuteur excusez-moi
pourront nous confirmer
je précise notamment que la DGE a piloté
le déploiement des enveloppes du plan de
France urlence ayant trait à la
relocalisation de capacités de
production pharmaceutiques entre autres
ça faisait partie des objectifs sur
laquelle je ne doute pas que nous aurons
de nombreuses questions
sur ce sujet des pénuries d'ailleurs la
publication forte opportunité hier soir
d'une première liste de 48 médicaments
critiques montrant à quel point ce sujet
est important et votre votre audition
fort bienvenu puisque vous avez su y
ajouter une pote des éléments et une
presto des éléments utiles
complémentaires vous nous direz
d'ailleurs comment cette liste a été
constituée puisqu'elle ne tient pas
compte je cite de notre capacité à
relocaliser et que pour certains
peut-être nous allons nous rendre compte
que nous n'en sommes pas capables et que
va s'ajouter ce qui pourrait paraître
pour autant primordial celle en tout cas
du point de vue de nos critères à nous
essentiels la liste des médicaments
critiques sur le plan thérapeutique
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat qu'elle fera l'objet
d'un compte-rendu publié avant de vous
donner la parole je vous rappelle qu'un
faux témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles
434-13 424-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite à prêter sermon de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure Monsieur Michel Raoul
vous intervenez ici monsieur pilser
et Monsieur Delattre
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
pour quelques propos liminaires et je
passerai ensuite la parole à notre
rapporteur Laurence Cohen pour une série
de questions complémentaires
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs je vous
remercie de cette invitation aujourd'hui
qui va me permettre de parler de
l'action de la DGE dans le domaine du
médicament
de manière générale notre rôle à la DGE
est de concevoir et de mettre en place
des politiques publiques qui concourent
au développement des entreprises donc on
porte des missions à la fois
sectorielles donc de politique
industrielle des missions transverses
par exemple tout ce qui est
simplification réglementaire et
politique d'innovation et également des
missions relatives à la transformation
écologique et numérique des entreprises
dans le secteur du médicament plus
spécifiquement
nous menons et nous suivant un certain
nombre de sujets qui concourt à la
compétitivité de la filière française
ainsi qu'à ses efforts de
réindustrialisation
nous participons pas directement à la
gestion des pénuries mais nous
collabrons étroitement avec le ministère
de la santé et la NSM sur le volet
industriel de cette gestion
dans les grandes lignes si je reprends
un peu l'historique de l'action de la
DGE avant la crise covid nous avions un
tropisme plutôt centré sur l'innovation
avec notamment l'objectif de positionner
la France comme un leader sur les
biothérapies et la bioproduction de ces
thérapies novembre
avec la crise covid il y a une prise de
conscience collective sur notre forte
dépendance industrielle ce qui nous a
amené à nous positionner plus fortement
sur ces enjeux de souveraineté
industrielle avec dans un premier temps
une réponse immédiate à la crise en
2020-2021 et dans un second temps une
réflexion plus structurée qui a aboutit
à la liste des M6 les médicaments
stratégiques d'un point de vue
industriel et sanitaire et je terminerai
enfin mon propos liminaire pour parler
des sujets européens
alors pour commencer quelques chiffres
sur la filière industrielle du
médicament en France en 2020 c'est 260
laboratoires pharmaceutiques répartis
sur plus de 400 sites industriels et une
quarantaine de façonniers ou également
appelé Sidi Moha qui travaille pour ces
donneurs d'ordre dont 24 qui produisent
des substances actives
cette industrie représente 63 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires dont la
moitié à l'export et entre 100 et 130
000 emplois directs
cela place la France en cinquième
position au niveau mondial en termes de
chiffre d'affaires derrière les
États-Unis la Chine le Japon et
l'Allemagne
et nous sommes en revanche en 5e
position en termes de production
pharmaceutique au sein de l'Union
européenne derrière enfin de l'Europe
pardon derrière la Suisse l'Italie
l'Allemagne et le Royaume-Uni
alors il faut distinguer deux segments
au sein du médicament
la bonne santé financière des grands
groupes ou des startups et souvent liées
à des produits innovants et donc plus
chers et masque une autre réalité qui
est que les producteurs et les
exploitants de molécules matures en gros
les médicaments génériques sont souvent
dans des situations économiques moins
favorables c'est générique représente 21
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
annuels donc environ un tiers
en ce qui concerne les actions mises en
oeuvre par la DGE je vais commencer par
février 2019 lorsque la filière
industrielle et l'État se sont
regroupées au sein d'un comité
stratégique de filière donc un CSF
appelé industrie et technologie de santé
présidée par la fefice l'ensemble des
révélations professionnelles et
représentées à ce bureau donc on y
trouve le LEM le sicos mais également le
Sidy et le système etc ainsi que les
administrations et les ministères donc
industrie recherche et santé en
particulier il s'agit d'une instance de
co-construction d'actions partagées
entre l'État industrie comme souhaité
par le Conseil national de l'industrie
afin d'avancer sur nos priorités
collectives
lors de la signature de ce premier
contrat en 2019 les grands défis
identifiés par la filière étaient
premièrement de consolider le leadership
français dans la production en
particulier en matière du propos du
production et deuxièmement de renforcer
l'internationalisation des entreprises
il avait donc été identifié dans ce
contrat je cite que en termes
d'indépendance sanitaire il est
important que la France se renforce dans
la production de thérapie innovantes
il y a donc eu un projet structurant sur
la bioproduction qui représente un gros
potentiel d'innovation technologique les
industriels du CSF ont donc étroitement
collaboré avec l'adge le ministère de la
santé et le ministère la recherche ce
qui nous a permis de définir et mettre
en oeuvre la stratégie d'accélération
biothérapie et de production annoncé en
2022 cette stratégie a pour objectif de
placer la France en tant que leader
mondial et de produire 20 biomédicaments
d'ici 2030
ensuite il y a eu la crise covid 2020
qui nous a fait prendre conscience de
difficultés majeures dans nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement en matière de
produits de santé c'est pour cela que le
gouvernement a lancé deux appels à
projets le premier capacité building
pour financer des projets qui visent à
répondre directement à la crise covid et
le second résilience pour renforcer nos
chaînes d'approvisionnement pour le
secteur de la santé le gouvernement a
donc mobilisé plus de 800 millions
d'euros d'aide pour à peu près 1,7
milliards d'euros d'investissement
productif donc public privé
concernant capacité building cet appel à
manifestation d'intérêt a permis
d'augmenter nos capacités de production
de traitement et de dispositifs utilisés
dans la lutte anti-covid par exemple
tout ce qui est respirateur oxygène
oxygénothérapie et également flacon et
seringue pour pour les vaccins covid les
671 millions d'euros investis par l'État
dans cette app dans cet ami ont permis
donc de soutenir 59 projets qui ont
mobilisé un virgule deux milliards
d'euros d'investissement public privé
c'est dans le cadre de cet appel à
manifestation d'un intérêt également que
l'État a financé une usine de production
du principe actif du paracétamol qui
sera active opérationnel en 2025 2026
ensuite concernant l'appel à projet
résilience c'était un appel à projet
plus large qui ne couvrait pas que le
périmètre santé mais sur le périmètre
santé ce sont 158 millions d'euros qui
ont été mobilisés cela a notamment
permis de mettre en place des filières
souveraines sur des produits en forte
pénurie durant la crise et de soutenir
des capacités de production de molécules
critiques en France 128 projets et 565
millions d'euros d'investissement public
privé
comme l'objectif de résilience était de
réduire nos dépendances dans un certain
nombre de secteurs stratégiques qui
allaient comme je disais au delà de la
santé par exemple avec l'agroalimentaire
et l'électronique et également de
relancer notre économie pour garantir la
création de valeur en France nous avons
donc regardé si les projets concernés
des médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeur mais nous avons également pris en
compte d'autres critères comme les
impacts sociaux et environnementaux des
projets en particulier on estime qu'il y
aura une création à terme de d'environ
6500 emplois suite à ces deux appels
parmi les projets soutenus plus d'une
centaine de projets médicaments et de
vaccins ont renforcé la chaîne de valeur
de ces médicaments MITM plus d'une
quarantaine on visait à la
relocalisation ou la sécurisation de
capacité de production de principes
actifs en particulier pour des molécules
utilisées en réanimation qui ont été en
forte tension pendant la crise
les capacités de production et également
été renforcées sur les tests de
diagnostic in vitro pour mettre en place
une filière souverain en France ainsi
que sur la chaîne de valeur des vaccins
pour permettre à la France d'avoir des
capacités de remplissage additionnels de
670 millions de doses par an
nous estimons qu'environ 10% des projets
soutenus sont actuellement achevés et la
durée de ces projets qui contient qui
contiennent souvent une phase de R&D en
amont de la phase d'industrialisation et
dans la majorité des cas plutôt de
l'ordre de 3-4 ans maximum 5 ans
ensuite passer l'urgence du contexte de
relance post covid et au-delà des
vulnérabilités spécifiques à la lutte
contre la covid 19 il a fallu donc
désormais structuré une approche
méthodologique qui permettait de cibler
les investissements en faveur de la
relocalisation de production de
médicaments
cela s'est traduit dans l'avenant au
contrat tragique de stratégiques de
filière en juin 2021 où a été décidé une
extension de son périmètre à une plus
grande part de la chaîne de valeur des
industries de santé la crise a en effet
montré l'urgence qu'il y a assuré la
résilience de notre industrie de santé
sur ce sujet de l'approvisionnement en
principe actif nous avons donc
collectivement créé un nouveau projet
relocalisation de principes actifs
intermédiaires ou médicament essentiels
et cela a notamment conduit à deux
livrables majeurs une étude sur la
vulnérabilité des chaînes de valeur du
principe actif et le second qui est la
construction de la liste des M6 par le
gouvernement
sur le premier livrable il s'agit d'une
étude menée pour le cycose par PwC qui a
permis de regarder spécifiquement les
questions de compétitivité de notre
industrie notamment au regard des
réglementations européennes c'est en
effet un des facteurs explicatifs de
notre dépendance grandissante au
fournisseurs asiatiques de principes
actifs
en effet vous le savez 40% des
médicaments aux commercialisés dans
l'Union européenne proviennent des pays
tiers et 60 à 80% des principes actifs
sont produits uniquement en Chine et en
Inde une molécule sur 6 n'est plus du
tout produite en Europe en particulier
les molécules matures
63% des lignes de production de
principes actifs
sont détenus par des fabricants
asiatiques contre 33% en Europe
cette proportion était inverse en 2000
et c'est en 2005 que l'Asie a attrapé
l'Europe
cette délocalisation progressive est en
partie due à des réglementation sociale
à environnementale qui sont plus
strictes et qui en Europe et qui bien
sûr a juste titre impose aux producteurs
des obligations en matière
environnementale par exemple tout ce qui
est rejet des solvants dans la rivière
contrôle de la pollution de l'air mais
également en matière sociale tout ce qui
est protection des travailleurs contre
les explosions l'inhalation de produits
toxiques etc les fabricants asiatiques
qui exportent en Europe ne sont pas
soumis à sa réglementation cette étude
estime que la mise en place d'une unité
de production de principes actifs en
Europe implique donc un surcoût de
l'ordre de 20 à 40% par rapport à une
production en Asie et une part
significative est liée au respect de ces
réglementations environnementales on
note néanmoins qu'il y a une forte
disparité selon le type de produit
ce constat m'amène aussi du coup à la
question du prix des médicaments la DGE
participent aux discussions
interministérielles au sein du CEPS
concernant la fixation du prix des
médicaments en particulier sur la mise
en oeuvre de l'article 65 de la LFSS
2022 le critère industriel ainsi que
l'article le 28 de l'accord 4 ceps
l'aime
ces outils permettent de répondre en
partie à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement lorsqu'il s'agit du
fait d'un prix trop faible néanmoins sur
le sujet plus large et global de la
régulation des produits de santé une
mission a été lancée par la première
ministre en janvier 2023 et elle se
donne pour objectif d’établir un
diagnostic partagé sur notre modèle de
prise en charge et ses voies
d'amélioration pour renforcer notre
compétitivité et mieux lutter contre les
tensions d'approvisionnement et les
pénuries
le système de soins français doit en
effet conseiller plusieurs objectifs
l'accès des patients médicaments la
lutte contre les pénuries le
renforcement du tissu productif
l'attractivité du territoire mais
également la soutenabilité des dépenses
et l'équilibre et l'équité dans la
répartition des efforts sur ces
questions très complexes nous serons
donc avant tout attentif aux conclusions
que rendra la mission surtout sujet de
réforme du financement des produits de
santé
excusez-moi si vous pouviez un peu
raccourcir votre propos de façon à ce
qu'on puisse avoir un échange et non
c'est une audition voilà très bien donc
le second alors je vais enchaîner sur
les M6 donc le son second livrable du
CSF c'est la liste des M6 donc la genèse
de la liste de CM6 vient du constat
qu'un préalable à la poursuite et à la
pérennisation des efforts de
relocalisation consiste à identifier
précisément les médicaments et les
principes actifs
dont la prolocalisation la production en
France est prioritaire du fait de trois
critères le premier et l'intérêt
thérapeutique le deuxième l'absence
alternative et le troisième la
vulnérabilité des chaînes de production
il fallait en effet disposer d'une liste
plus restreinte que celle des MITM qui
représente 6000 molécules voire
concentrer nos efforts et maximiser
notre impact en termes de souveraineté
sanitaire industrielle donc un groupe de
travail était engagé en 2022 entre la
DGE la DGS et la NSM pour constituer une
telle liste de médicaments suite aux
recommandations des rapports bio et
récemment Géorgie dans ce processus la
DGS et la NSM
identifie les médicaments les plus
stratégiques du point de vue de leur
intérêt à thérapeutique
et ensuite la des gemmène avec la NSM
une analyse de la vulnérabilité
industrielle de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement en prenant en compte
notamment la dépendance aux
approvisionnements extraieue on s'appuie
donc sur des analyses des ruptures et
les sites de production déclarés pour
ces médicaments pour identifier ceux
dont la chaîne de production est la plus
fragile et enfin nous faisons le lien
avec les industriels du CSF pour qu'il
challenge notre analyse qu'ils étudient
les causes profondes et vulnérabilité
ainsi que la faisabilité et le coût
d'une éventuelle relocalisation
notre stratégie industrielle pour
terminer doit également se construire au
niveau européen donc
era l'Agence européenne de réponse aux
crises est un élément de réponse et nous
soutenons avec la DGS le fait qu'elle
puisse avoir des objectifs ambitieux
elle a un rôle majeur à jouer pour
sécuriser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour répondre aux
crises sanitaires
et par ailleurs au vu des différences de
marché identifiées pour le secteur de la
santé la France a proposé en 2021 de
mettre en place et de coordonner un
projet important d'intérêt européen
commun donc un pied sur la santé pour
répondre à plusieurs objectifs
promouvoir le développement et le
déploiement de procédés de production
plus durable et disruptif favoriser
l'énergie l'émergence de thérapie
innovantes et contribuer aux efforts
européens pour renforcer la résilience
de l'Union c'est donc la DGE qui
coordonne en Inde ministériel cette
initiative
en deux mots un pied avec c'est un
projet important comme je disais
d'intérêt européen commun c'est d'abord
un outil qui permet à des États membres
après avoir l'accord de la Commission
européenne de financer des projets
industriels qui dépassent les seuils
habituellement autorisés que ce soit en
montant ou en pourcentage d'aide donc un
pied qui permet de déroger à ses seuils
mais à une double condition qui est une
coalition d'État membre engagée pour
avoir un véritable effet de passage à
l'échelle et que les projets répondent à
une faille de marché c'est à dire que
les conditions du marché d'un point de
vue économique ou technologique n'incite
pas naturellement les entreprises à
investir il y a donc un critère
d'innovation très strict et la
Commission ne valide que les projets qui
déploient des technologies qui vont
au-delà de l'état de l'art
le pied accenté a donc été énoncé en
mars 2022 sous PFUE il a été conçu en
deux vagues avec un budget d'environ 1,5
millions d'euros pour mettre en place
une politique industrielle européenne
mais pas pour répondre spécifiquement
aux problèmes de pénurie de médicaments
au vu des exigences d'innovation que je
mentionnais
nous avons donc sélectionné trois
projets qui ont été notifiés à la
Commission donc 1 qui portent
spécifiquement sur le recours à des
procédés innovants pour une chaîne de
production de principes critiques plus
verte et mieux intégrés à l'échelons
européens
pour résumer nous avons donc engagé au
sortir de la crise covid un certain
nombre d'actions structurantes qui vise
à réindustrialiser la France et à
rétablir un certain degré de
souveraineté industrielle et sanitaires
ce sont des actions qui sont néanmoins à
leur début et nous devrons sans doute
encore attendre quelques années avant de
voir pleinement leurs effets
merci beaucoup pour ces propos
liminaires complets je vais donc
demander à Laurence Cohen rapporteur
donc
c'est une première salle de question
oui merci madame la Présidente je dois
dire que même après votre propos
liminaire et si l'intérêt d'une
commission d'enquête pour avoir des
réponses précises à des questions
précises il me reste des interrogations
sur le ciblage et les conditions des
programmes d'aide à la relocalisation
selon la presse seuls 18 projets sur une
centaine financée par le plan de relance
permettront en réalité de relocaliser la
production de principes actifs ou
d'ingrédients de médicaments est-ce que
vous confirmez ces chiffres et comment
ces projets ont-ils été choisi parce que
vous avez donné un certain nombre de
chiffres qui ont été au-delà de ces 18
projets mais on voudrait des je voudrais
nous voudrions des éléments beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus précis par exemple
quand je vous demande quels sont les
critères qui ont présidé à ces choix
vous avez donné comme exemple le
paracétamol et effectivement l'usine
séquence qu'on est allé visiter avec
avec la présidente enfin on a plutôt
visité la plateforme on a rencontré les
équipes parce que l'usine est en train
de sortir de terre elle est pas sortie
mais bon d'accord c'est le paracétamol
c'est bien on se réjouit mais pourquoi
il y a pas de projet sur l'amoxicilline
par exemple donc c'est vraiment
quels sont vos critères de choix ça
c'est ma première question
ma seconde question elle est plus sur le
ciblage et les conditions des programmes
d'aide à leur localisation
aujourd'hui on est face à une situation
de pénurie de tension
c'est une situation qui est qui est
générale on peut dire qui est mondial
mais il y a une pratique depuis des
dizaines d'années de délocalisation vous
l'avez un peu dit c'est-à-dire cette
délocalisation pour gagner sur les coûts
aussi bien au niveau de la main d'oeuvre
que pour gagner aussi sur les coups au
niveau environnemental donc il y a eu un
choix de délocalisation aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez équitable juste
que le gouvernement est bien finalement
des blocs des fonds publics pour
permettre à ces mêmes entreprises qui
ont délocalisé de se relocaliser est-ce
que vous trouvez que cette équitable et
même que c'est éthique et là je me fais
le relais d'un certain nombre de de
professeurs de médecine qui d'ailleurs
ont dénoncé cet état de fait à juste à
juste titre alors est-ce que dans le
recommandation si je me réfère donc
est-ce qu'ils ont écrit le recommandé
plutôt de créer un établissement public
à but non lucratif pour mettre en oeuvre
des partenariats publics privés visant à
coordonner la stratégie de
relocalisation donc à la fois qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ces critiques et
finalement comment est-ce qui est reçu
au niveau de la direction générale des
entreprises donc du gouvernement cette
proposition est-ce qu'elle est
travaillée est-ce qu'elle est réfléchie
ma troisième ma troisième question c'est
toujours sur les aides à la
relocalisation
est-ce que si les aides à la
relocalisation c'est compliqué à dire
finance aujourd'hui des projets donc de
modernisation et de renforcement de
capacité de production qui existe en
France est-ce que cela signifie que vous
estimez encore aujourd'hui un
déséquilibre de compétitivité de
l'industrie pharmaceutique française par
rapport à d'autres pays notamment
européens donc en fait qu'est-ce que
vous allez mettre comme conditionnalité
aux aides à la relocalisation et la
réindustrie à la réindustrialisation
ciblée
parce que mon souci et notre souci c'est
qu'il faudrait pas qu'il y ait à nouveau
de l'argent public qui soit débloqué
pour inciter les entreprises à
relocaliser et que dans très peu de
temps et bien elle redécalise voyez-vous
et quand je parle de relocalisation il
est bien évident que personne au niveau
de la commission d'enquête ne pense
qu'il faut relocaliser à toute force sur
le sur le territoire exclusivement
national il faut qu'il y ait des
relocalisations niveau national mais il
faut réfléchir évidemment au niveau
européen avec une coordination une
harmonisation donc c'est de ça dont je
parle
la quatrième la quatrième question
finalement
[Musique]
on s'aperçoit que les les groupes
pharmaceutiques
françaises
notamment français pardon
sont assez peu performants en matière
d'innovation
alors comment vous arrivez à analyser le
fait que à la fois il y a une très forte
dépense publique concernant
recherche et développement et une
performance relativement peu
satisfaisante en matière d'innovation et
donc il se répercute sur les sur les
patients là il y a quand même une
contradiction très forte
ma cinquième question et vous l'avez
vous l'avez et évoqué dans votre propos
liminaire et d'ailleurs vous avez été
interrogé sur le sujet mais vous n'avez
pas répondu à la question il y a une
première liste de 48 médicaments
critiques qui a été arrêté par par Bercy
nous nous réjouissons au niveau de la
commission d'enquête parce que nous
remarquons qu'elle est suivie avec
assiduité par le cabinet les cabinets
gouvernementaux du gouvernement plutôt
que ce soit au niveau de Bercy à mon
avis au niveau de la santé c'est une
très bonne chose parce que quand on
travaille c'est pour le bien commun et
on remarque qu'il y a souvent des
annonces la veille d'un certain nombre
d'auditions donc à la fois ces flatteurs
mais en même temps on s'interroge et
pourquoi je m'interroge sur les 48
médicaments que critiques et bien parce
que je vais reprendre les propos que
vous avez tenus monsieur pilser ou pile
c'est je ne sais pas
d'accord vous avez dit donc concernant
cette liste on l'a constitué sans
prendre en compte notre capacité à
relocaliser ces médicaments pour
certains nous allons nous rendre compte
que nous n'en sommes pas capables
alors qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
c'est quoi voilà c'est à dire que si
vous voulez là on est un peu dans un on
n'a pas très bien compris
c'est-à-dire c'est quoi les alternatives
en localiser vous n'en aurez pas la
capacité ça ne sera pas possible vous
avez quand même j'imagine un plan de
relocalisation au niveau européen ou
c'est une constatation auquel cas
mes doutes pour ne pas dire pour ne pas
dire autre chose donc ça c'est une
question importante
exactement ça ne tient pas compte de
l'intérêt
de l'intérêt thérapeutique alors nous
nous sommes au niveau de la commission
d'enquête au niveau de notre réflexion
pour effectivement une liste restreinte
de produits là vous avez les 48 si j'ai
bien compris c'est un premier sa cible
un certain nombre de de molécules mais
ça n'est pas global ça n'est pas la
liste définitive bien évidemment mais
nous nous sommes plus sur une liste
autour d'une centaine de produits qui
est pas 3000 produits parce que sinon
3000 médicaments parce que sinon on n'y
arrive pas donc voilà des précisions sur
sur ces éléments s'il vous plaît et la
dernière question ça concerne les les
pieds parce que nous nous sommes
déplacés à Bruxelles notamment et nous
avons eu énormément de mal à obtenir des
informations précise sur cette
initiative qui est quand même une
initiative ancienne mais nous n'avions
pas de données très très précis sur le
nombre de projets qui avaient été mené à
bien alors vous avez parlé de trois
projets que vous avez sélectionné mais
j'aimerais beaucoup plus de précisions
sur ces projets et j'aimerais savoir
quels sont les acteurs industriels ou
ceux de la recherche au niveau français
qui sont engagés dans ce piège ou ces
pièces il y en a trois je vous remercie
d'avance
je vous laisse répondre j'ai une autre
pardonnez-moi j'ai oublié une question
je vous avais dit que vous étiez associé
à la fixation des prix avec le CEPS
c'est très intéressant il y a une grande
opacité qui règne sur cette fixation des
prix et ça crée beaucoup de malentendus
de tension de doute au niveau de la
population d'ailleurs et quand on nous
dit par exemple les prix des
des médicaments matures sont trop bas
quid sur quoi sur quoi on se base et moi
je vous demande qu'est-ce que vous
penseriez qu'il y ait une transparence
sur la fixation des prix et que dans
cette transparence on prenne en compte à
la fois le coût réel de production
le respect des normes environnementales
et sociales parce que si vous voulez si
des entreprises sont relocalisées
qu'elles ont qu'elles respectent en
France et en Europe des normes qui ont
été établis collectivement il serait pas
normal qu'elle soit en concurrence avec
des entreprises qui ne respectent pas
ces normes-là parce qu'elles viennent
d'ailleurs donc respect de ces normes
évidemment évaluation du service médical
rendu et quatrième j'allais dire
conditions de transparence bien la marge
bénéficiaire qui est reconnue par tous
mais qu'on est ces quatre éléments là
qui soient
identifiés et qu'on sache exactement
quel est le prix parce que sinon on voit
des prix notamment de de médicaments
innovants qui s'envolent
et qui sont absolument on sait pas sur
quoi on s'appuie pour la fixation de ce
genre de prix et du coup on réduit
toujours par le bas les médicaments
mature mais à un moment donné c'est plus
possible de les de les produire dans de
telles conditions je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour ces questions alors
je vais
ils répondent dans le désordre
je vais peut-être commencer sur tout ce
qui concerne cette liste de médicaments
stratégiques d'un point de vue
industriel et sanitaire donc c'est
une construction commune avec le
ministère de la Santé dans un premier
temps le ministère de la Santé consulte
notamment les sociétés savantes et
établies la liste des médicaments
critiques cette liste de médicaments
critique les critiques d'un point de vue
sanitaire thérapeutique donc ce sont des
médicaments essentiels pour notre
système de soins donc des médicaments
qui s'il n'était plus sur le marché
mettaient en difficulté les les patients
en partant de cette liste de médicaments
critiques
la DGE constitue un sous-ensemble qui
est cette liste de M6 donc ce sont des
médicaments qui par définition sont des
mouvements critiques donc important d'un
point de vue thérapeutique mais sur
lequel la chaîne
d'approvisionnement et fortement
délocalisé
on prend en compte un certain nombre de
critères pour industriel notamment
combien y a-t-il d'exploitants est-ce
que il y a ce produit e-commercié par un
seul exploitant notamment est-ce qu'il y
a une situation de monopole combien y
a-t-il de producteurs de principes
actifs combien y a-t-il de producteurs
du produit fini et la part de cette
production qui est réalisée en Europe
cela nous permet de d'apprécier
si nous sommes fortement à risque qui
est un problème sur une chaîne de valeur
sur la chaîne de valeur de production du
médicament
la liste des médicaments critiques elle
est adossée à un ensemble de
d'actions qui sont mises en oeuvre d'une
part par le ministère de la Santé tout
ce qui est prévisions anticipation
gestion des pénuries etc et pour ce qui
concerne ce sous-ensemble donc la liste
des médicaments stratégiques d'un point
de vue industriel et sanitaire c'est sur
cette liste que nous nous basons pour
prioriser nos efforts de relocalisation
donc nous regardons au cas par cas
et nous en discutons avec les
industriels pour voir
s'ils peuvent oui ou non relocaliser
la production du principe actif ou du
produit fini en France
cette
par-construction la méthodologie que
nous appliquons qui est donc à l'issue
du rapport Géorgie modulo modulo des
adaptations mineures
prend en compte les implantations au
niveau européen donc un médicament qui
est produit en Europe
sur lesquels il y a beaucoup de
producteurs sur lequel la part des
producteurs européens
producteurs européens est élevé sera ne
sera pas considéré comme étant un
médicament stratégique
donc nous n'allons pas regarder si nous
le si nous avons besoin de leur
relocaliser nous considérons que
le fait d'avoir beaucoup de producteurs
en Europe est un gage de garantie de
sécurité d'approvisionnement
alors concernant ensuite
la question sur le pied
donc
le principe du pied et effectivement
ancien je sais pas exactement de quand
il date mais comme je vous le disais le
pied qui est un est avant tout un outil
juridique donc c'est un outil qui permet
à des États membres de demander un
accord à la Commission
pour
pour financer des projets au-delà des
seuils autorisés donc il y a eu
plusieurs pieds qui ont été lancés des
pièces sur la Nano électronique sur le
Cloud sur
d'autres d'autres thématiques
le pied accenté en l'occurrence est un
projet qui a été lancé en
2021-2022 et dans le cadre de ce
processus il y a une durant une
quarantaine de projets qui sont pour la
première vague
qui ont été notifiés par l'ensemble des
États membres parties prenantes à la
Commission européenne
dont trois projets en France à ce stade
je ne peux pas vous communiquer le
le détail de ces projets puisque ils
n'ont pas encore été
rendus publics et nous attendons
également des retours de la commission
je pourrais vous faire parvenir par
écrit si vous le souhaitez les détails
concernant les projets que la France a
retenu pour
vous demandera cette liste par écrit
Merci
ensuite sur la question
du CEPS
nous pensons qu'il y a
que les modalités de fixation du prix
sont déjà
répondent déjà un objectif de
transparence la loi FX les critères qui
sont explicitants pris en compte dans la
tarification des produits de santé et
l'accord cadre entre le CEPS et le LEM
détail les dispositions qui peuvent être
mobilisées pour par exemple octroyer des
stabilité de prix
à des médicaments
pardonnez-moi mais vous êtes sur une
commission d'enquête vous devez vraiment
répondre aux questions et quand et c'est
là là c'est la langue de bois parce que
c'est que c'est transparent je pense que
ceux qui nous écoutent et même nous on
s'est retenus d'avoir un fou rire c'est
parce que c'est tout sauf transparent
voilà donc il y a des prix faciaux qui
sont publiés les prix nets sont
négociées entre les entreprises et le
CEPS ils ne sont pas communiqués pour
des raisons de secrets des affaires
sur la vous posiez la question de savoir
s'il fallait prendre en compte le coût
d'un médicament dans la fixation de son
tarif
cette question est complexe elle
présente selon moi des avantages et des
inconvénients
l'avantage étant qu'effectivement en se
calant sur une approche coup plus marge
garantie qu'un produit que la production
d'un produit est rentable et donc on
s'assure qu'il y a une production à une
commercialisation
l'inconvénient en revanche et d'une part
la difficulté à contrôler la fiabilité
des informations donc il faut pouvoir
accéder à une comptabilité analytique
pour challenger les entreprises sur le
coût réel toutes les entreprises n'ont
pas des comptabilité analytiques et
deuxièmement ce dispositif pourrait
créer des incitations enfin des
mauvaises incitations dans le système
qui inciterait qui enlèverait
l'incitation car l'industrielle à
optimiser son coût à partir du moment où
les garantit qu'il sera payé à son coût
plus ça marche il fera moins d'effort
pour réduire ce coup là donc ça cela
aura un impact sur
sur les dépenses sur les dépenses
publiques
concernant le
d'accord
concernant la question de
du respect des normes effectivement
c'est un des facteurs qui explique les
différences de compétitivité
la commission
européenne dans sa communication récente
sur le paquet Pharma pharmaceutique a
proposé qu'il y ait une inclusion
systématique d'une évaluation des
risques environnementaux pour tous les
médicaments qui seraient commercialisés
en Europe
il nous semble que c'est un premier pas
intéressant qu'il doit y avoir une
meilleure coordination européenne à cet
effet pour qu'il puisse y avoir une
harmonisation des normes qui sont
demandées
à tous les producteurs peu importe leur
localisation à partir du moment où ils
exportent des médicaments en Europe
ensuite sur la question
sur le ciblage des aides du plan France
relance
sur le plan France relance
j'ai mentionné plus de 800 millions
d'euros d'aide
la le chiffre exact est de 829 millions
d'euros
la majorité de ces aides 671 millions
ont été fléchés vers la limite capacity
donc était vraiment
l'appel à projet qui visait à
sélectionner des des projets industriels
pour répondre à nos besoins de
médicaments et de dispositif pour la
crise covid ensuite c'est 158 millions
d'euros pour résilience
OK
très bien
la façon dont ces projets ont été
choisis et effectivement d'avoir
des projets qui permettent de relancer
notre économie de soutenir des projets
de réimplantation industrielle nous
avons regardé si les projets étaient
effectivement des MTM à l'époque nous
disposions pas de la liste des M6 des
médicaments stratégiques donc nous avons
regardé si les projets étaient des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs nous avons également regardé
s'il y avait des projets qui
concernaient des modernisations de ligne
avec des nouveaux procédés de production
notamment par exemple la chimie en flux
continu qui permet de dépenser moins
d'énergie des maîtres moins de gaz à
effet de serre
nous avons regardé s'il y avait des
projets qui est permettait également
d'augmenter les capacités de production
sur des principes actifs sur lesquels
nous avions de petites capacités de
production mais il a fallu augmenter ses
capacités pour passer à l'échelle nous
avons regardé s'il y avait aussi des
impacts sur l'emploi notamment s'il y
avait des projets qui étaient fortement
créateurs créateurs d'emplois donc c'est
toute cette analyse multipritères qui
nous a conduit à sélectionner les
projets comme nous l'avons fait
sur la liste notamment là puisque j'ai
interpellé monsieur pilsert
sur alors sur la liste de médicaments en
fait il y a une première liste de 20
médicaments qui avait été déjà annoncé
en février de mémoire
c'est un travail progressif donc nous
procédons par air thérapeutique donc on
a nous avons commencé par regarder tous
les médicaments utilisés en anesthésie
réanimation en cardiologie en oncologie
et nous allons étendre progressivement
ce travail à d'autres thérapeutiques
donc c'est c'est un travail qui sera
qui cédera sur sans doute plusieurs mois
sur lequel nous allons étudier r par air
les médicaments
que nous avons besoin de de relocaliser
donc le premier travail qui avait
conduit en février avoir une liste de 20
médicaments ensuite abouti aujourd'hui à
ce que nous ayons
48 médicaments et nous en aurons plus
la DGS a émotionné effectivement à la
fin l'objectif d'avoir de à 300 M6 au
total ce qui est une très forte
sélection par rapport à l'ensemble des
item puisqu'il y a 6000 6000 amittm
vous aviez une question aussi sur est-ce
qu'il existe encore un déséquilibre de
compétitivité dans l'Europe et les
contreparties que nous pourrions
demander alors ce déséquilibre de
compétitivité
dans l'Europe et plus difficilement
plus difficilement quantifiable il
dépend d'autres facteurs donc moins des
facteurs environnementaux que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure puisqu'il y a
des puisque les réglementations par
définition européennes sont applicables
à tous les États membres européens il
peut y avoir des déficits des
différences de compétitivité au niveau
de la main d'oeuvre la production de
certains principes actifs nécessitent
des opérations très complexes qui sont
intensives en main d'oeuvre et donc il
peut y avoir le coût du travail qui peut
varier qui peuvent varier d'un d'un
pays à l'autre en ce qui concerne le
fait d'offrir de la prévisibilité aux
industriels
l'approche qui a été retenue et
finalement celle de l'article 65 de la
FS 2022 le critère industriel
qui permet de donner un avantage en
termes de prix du médicament à ceux dont
la production dont la chaîne de
production est mieux implantée en Europe
et permet de garantir une sécurité
d'approvisionnement
alors je vais vous demander de préciser
un certain nombre de choses parce que
il y a vraiment besoin d'avoir plus
d'éléments dans un échange plus direct
sur les questions et les réponses par
exemple quand vous dites que au niveau
du prix vous avez effectivement vous
prenez en compte la le comment dirais-je
un critère de relocalisation
industrielle etc très précisément
comment combien de fois la Direction
Générale des Entreprises est intervenu
auprès du CEPS par rapport à pour faire
entrer en fait ce critère précis
d'industrialisation dans dans le prix ça
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question vous avez parlé de vous avez
dit exactement pour ne pas trahir votre
votre peau qu'à partir du moment où un
médicament est produit en Europe il
n'est pas considéré comme un médicament
stratégique parce que vous considérez
que du coup il ne devrait pas souffrir
de de pénurie grosso modo or moi je
voudrais vous préciser parce que
qu'est-ce que veut dire médicament vous
parlez de quoi est-ce que vous parlez du
principe actif est-ce que vous parlez du
produit fini est-ce que vous parlez de
tel ou tel substance chimiques qui sont
nécessaires à la fabrication vous voyez
bien que là on n'est pas sur les sur les
mêmes sur les mêmes échelles ça c'est ma
deuxième demande de de précision ensuite
quand je vous dis par exemple j'ai parlé
de la comment dirais-je de la politique
qui a été menée vous n'avez absolument
pas répondu c'est à dire ça fait depuis
des dizaines d'années qui a eu une
politique qui a été menée par les
industries les industriels c'est-à-dire
de délocalisation je vous ai je vous ai
fait
comment état de proposition d'un certain
nombre de professeurs de médecine qui
recommandait par exemple un
établissement à but non lucratif pour
mettre en oeuvre des partenariats
publics privés justement parce que
est-ce que c'est vraiment éthique
déontologique de redonner de l'argent
public à des entreprises pour qu'elles
relocalise et avec une incertitude et
vous n'avez pas non plus répondre sur
les exigences les conditionnalités qui
parce que sinon elles peuvent pro
délocaliser dans d'ici un an deux ans
trois ans cinq ans donc il faut un peu
voilà les les finances publiques se sont
pas des des puits depuis sans fond donc
il faut avoir quand même un certain
nombre d'exigences donc voilà moi dans
un premier temps les les éléments qui me
viennent qui me viennent à l'esprit par
rapport à
aux réponses que vous avez
tenté de faire
donc concernant l'article 65 sa doctrine
d'application n'a été que très récemment
finalisé donc nous n'avons pas encore
suffisamment de recul pour
pour pour apprécier l'effet qu'il a eu
je n'ai pas exactement en tête le nombre
de fois où il a pu être mobilisé donc je
vous répondrai par écrit par écrit
là-dessus
concernant les M6 effectivement j'ai
précisé qu'un médicament qui était
produit en Europe pour nous il n'était
pas considéré comme stratégique alors
pas forcément dans le sens où on
considère qu'il n'y aura jamais de
pénurie mais plutôt dans le sens où
nous savons que nous avons une capacité
de production en Europe et donc on se
prémine un certain nombre de risques qui
peuvent être des risques extrêmes comme
les fermetures des frontières risques
qui peuvent exister on a eu on aurait pu
avoir ce cas là lorsqu'il y a eu la
flambée de l'épidémie de covid en Chine
et où on a pu craindre que la Chine
ferme ses frontières pour l'exportation
de principes actifs
donc cette cette méthodologie je
pourrais si vous voulez vous en faire
parvenir le détail en fait elle est
effectivement elle prend en compte
l'ensemble des critères que vous ment
donc le nombre de laboratoires qui
exploite ce médicament le nombre de
fournisseurs du principe actif la part
de ces sites de production de principes
actifs qui sont en Europe et en Europe
le nombre de sites de production du
produit fini et la part de ces sites de
production de produits qui sont en
Europe et en Europe donc on regarde
l'ensemble de ces critères là pour
apprécier pour donner un score
finalement c'est un score sur 20 à la
fin qui nous permet de dire si on
considère que le médicament est
stratégique ou pas on prend en compte
deux critères additionnels
un critère additionnel qui est est-ce
que la part des sites de production de
principes actifs
fait en dehors de l'Europe et supérieure
à 30% et le dernier critère et de savoir
si on a constaté en moyenne au moins
trois ruptures par an sur la période
2018-2021
et donc c'est en analysant tous ces
critères là qu'on regarde si
le médicament est
considéré d'un point de vue considéré
stratégique d'un point de vue industriel
sur la question du des engagements que
nous pourrions demander en contrepartie
des des subventions des aides à la
relocalisation à la réindustrialisation
c'est effectivement une question
importante
nous réfléchissons effectivement à
demander dans le cadre de futurs actions
de relocalisation qui pour aujourd'hui
pour le pour l'instant non pas encore
été engagé mais ne réfléchissons
effectivement à
demander aux industriels à ce qui
s'engagent à des clauses sur de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement donc des
clauses qui permettent à l'état de
demander un industriel de fournir en
priorité ou d'accélérer des livraisons
pour le match pour le marché français si
on constate si on constate des pénuries
et sur la dernière question de la
constitution d'un pôle public privé pour
la relocalisation et la production des
médicaments c'est une question
c'est une question qui n'est pas simple
je pense que
un tel pôle pourrait redonner la main à
la puissance publique pour
choisir de produire un médicament ou non
il y a un certain nombre néanmoins de
difficultés opérationnelles qui peuvent
se poser la question de la compétitivité
compétitivité de ce pôle dans la durée
n'est pas forcément évidente il faudra
investir il faudra trouver les
compétences ou les nouvelles
technologies etc mais si on avait un tel
pôle public ou public privé de
production cela ne résoudrait pas
toujours la question du prix du
médicament on sait que c'est cette fois
parfois enfin dans un certain nombre de
cas la décision d'un industriel de ne
pas produire
un
médicament en Europe ou en France et
surtout lié à des questions de
rentabilité à d'écart entre son coup de
production et le tarif qui est
qui est proposé négocié avec le CEPS
donc il faut aussi
à mon sens avant tout regarder les
effets que vont avoir l'application de
l'article 65 et de l'article 28 suite
aux nouvelles orientations
ministérielles pour savoir si ça va
avoir un vrai impact un impact
significatif sur les incitations aux
industriels à produire plus en France et
en Europe
si j'ai bien compris en fait vous ne
demandez aucune condition
aux entreprises
c'est à dire que là quand vous proposez
vous inciter à la relocalisation il y a
aucune conditionnalité par rapport aux
aides que le gouvernement va donner
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas un engagement
pour que l'entreprise reste x temps sur
le territoire français ou produisent
enfin voilà je veux dire que là encore
on est sur des aides publiques qui sont
donnés
sans du tout avoir oui de critères de
conditionnalités j'ai bien compris ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question est-ce que
au niveau du CEPS puisque vous avez vous
êtes dans les négociations est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui par rapport aux
médicaments matures
qui sont en risque de pénurie vous
défendez la hausse des produits matures
puisque c'est une des revendications qui
est venue lors de nos de nos auditions
où vous en êtes puisque on sait que lors
de l'examen du budget de la Sécurité
sociale au niveau du Parlement
l'enveloppe
du médicament et de la variable
d'ajustement et que malheureusement on
joue
au Vasse communicants c'est-à-dire que
on baisse le coût le coup des
médicaments en mature pour répondre aux
demandes exorbitantes concernant les
médicaments innovants et à ce petit jeu
là à un moment donné on peut risquer de
ne plus avoir de médicaments matures
parce que les industriels vont trouver
que c'est réellement pas non rentable
donc ma question elle est précise est-ce
que vous défendez une hausse des
médicaments matures en risque de pénurie
deux questions très précises alors sur
la première question aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas lancé de dispositif hormis
ceux que j'ai cité donc qui sont clos
donc capacité building résilience nous
n'avons pas lancé de nouveaux
dispositifs de soutien à la à la
relocalisation donc ce que je vous
disais c'est qu'effectivement nous
réfléchissons dans le cadre de futurs
potentiels à venir à intégrer des
demandes d'engagement de sécurisation
d'approvisionnement du marché français
celle que vous avez déjà lancée est-ce
qu'il y avait des conditions
en gros pour le alors je vais être très
précise puisque vous vous ne semblez je
dois pas être suffisamment clair il y a
une entreprise qui s'appelle séquence
qui est en train qui est en train de
monter son
usine quels ont été les conditionnalités
qui leur a qui leur ont été demandés
pour être sûr que il n'est pas une
délocalisation dans quelques années ça
c'est clair et précis c'est passé donc
vous pouvez me répondre oui ou non
je ne sais pas oui effectivement je
n'ai pas ces informations là donc je
vous répondrai par écrit sur cette
question concernant séquence oui
concernant la deuxième question est-ce
que nous défendons des hausses de prix
pour les médicaments
matures
effectivement il y a eu des orientations
ministérielles des idées photocopies
pénuries dans lesquelles les ministres
ont demandé à ce que le CEPS regarde
attentivement les demandes de hausse de
prix enfin ils sont d'abord annoncé un
moratoire sur les génériques M6 et
ensuite à ce qu'on regarde attentivement
les demandes de hausse de prix pour ces
pour CM6 qui seraient produire en Europe
donc pour ces médicaments matures je ne
peux pas vous dire là tout de suite
combien de dossiers ont été déposés ou
pas donc je pourrais vous répondre
également par écrit là-dessus mais
effectivement nous sommes collectivement
avec l'ensemble des ministères
représentés au CEPS attentif à ce que
ces orientations soient respectées et
que pour les médicaments stratégiques
qui le justifient qui représentent un
enjeu de santé publique nous puissions
regarder l'ensemble des hausses des
dépenses éligibles pour octroyer une
hausse de coût au titre de l'article 28
de la corcadre
merci donc je vais je vais compléter les
questions
la fameuse liste des 48 est-ce qu'il est
possible de l'avoir
deuxième question corollaire pourquoi
vous avez priorisé oncologie anesthésie
réa et puis certains médicaments utiles
en crise lesquelles quoi je suis
vraiment ce 48 ça fait pas beaucoup par
rapport aux 6000 MITM donc on voudrait
savoir quoi et c'est c'est pas non plus
les 150 à 200 au final
si j'ai bien compris le process vous
êtes en fin vous êtes l'ensemble des
parties prenantes sur cette question des
pénuries de médicaments et la
constitutionnalisme parce que on a du
mal à savoir qui fait quoi précisément
et qu'on aimerait bien que tout le monde
fasse un peu convergent donc l'ensemble
des patries d'une partie prenante est en
cours de de consultation des sociétés
savantes
honnêtement les sociétés savantes la
consultation ça a amené aux 3000 à 6000
MTM enfin on avait un objectif de
là on en a déjà 48 il reste beaucoup
beaucoup de sociétés savantes à
interroger je
ça va être compliqué donc
c'est un sujet
quid de c'est du lien de cette liste
avec celle de l'OMS quid du lien de
cette liste avec celle qui est en cours
de constitution par l'Agence européenne
du médicament
voilà c'est des sujets qui sont
importants est-ce que ça va être une
liste limitative arrêtée ou une liste
qui pourra bouger dans le temps
c'est un vrai sujet on vous interroge là
dessus parce que l'annonce vient d'être
faite par vous donc d'un certain nombre
de précisions donc finalement quelque
part outre l'intérêt thérapeutique qui
manifestement n'est pas de votre ressort
ou en tout cas dans un second temps on
va être réévalué pour le reste on
aimerait savoir
vous évoquez cette question de de la
souveraineté dans les choix qui ont été
faits dans le cadre du Plan relance il y
a eu de vos propos d'ailleurs vous-même
puisque je reprends des verbatifs
d'intervention tout ça des uns et des
autres il y a eu aussi des échecs dans
les choix de dès à présent des échecs
dans les choix d'accompagnement je pense
qu'il y en a un qui a été cité et qui
qui
fabrique des des poches des poches de
perfusion de paracétamol
on est bien d'accord
car Elide en tout cas moi je j'invente
pas enfin je ce que je veux dire c'est
que je je me fie à des verbaties mais
des contenus d'un intervention publique
et j'ai pris exactement les mots et les
termes qui ont été utilisés il y a donc
5 millions d'euros d'accompagnement dans
le cadre du Plan relance
et puis finalement les hôpitaux ont
continué et puis les acheteurs publics
on continuait à acheter à l'étranger
parce que
parce que la masse budgétaire de
commande escalier que quelques centimes
pour une poche ça fait beaucoup beaucoup
au final sur les sur les lots complets
et que encore une fois traité de ces
questions là sans comment dire
sans tenir compte de la seconde ligne
puisqu'il y en a plusieurs lignes
budgétaires dans lequel FSS qui est à
dire la ligne hôpital qui est aussi
limitée dans le cadre du PLFSS c'est
compliqué donc vous aviez d'ailleurs il
a été annoncé
circulaire a été envoyé aux acheteurs
publics pour privilégier enfin pas
privilégier mais pour prendre en compte
le critère de circuit court ou en tout
cas de sécurité d'approvisionnement et
on sait que avec les dérivés les poches
et certains dérivés
injectables
c'était essentiel que le fait que ce
soit
en Asie compromis beaucoup beaucoup la
sécurité d'approvisionnement pour le
coup les quelques sentiments plus là ils
vont peser lourd dans la balance et
notamment dans la balance de la ligne
hôpital tout ça pour vous dire que
comment vous envisagez en fait vos
décisions parce que là on est un peu
sous le coup de cette annonce mais
comment vous envisagez vos décisions
votre place à vous dans ce système de
financement de la santé en France qui
est sous le joug du
sacro-saint- ondame puis LFSS et des
lignes budgétaires médicament hôpital
que là on traite vraiment de de la
question du médicament et comment ça
s'articule voilà pour que vous soyez à
la fois efficace en matière de de
réindustrialisation et de souveraineté
et que en même temps on explose pas les
déficits de la Sécurité sociale
voilà c'est donc ma deuxième question
celle-là parce que c'est un vrai sujet
et on a bien compris qu'il y avait un
COPIL mais ce n'est que pile on en a vu
beaucoup des tasses fortes tout ça donc
on aimerait savoir comment ça fonctionne
ma troisième question concerne les les
ce que vous appelez la production
européenne ce que vous regardez et
française bien évidemment en matière de
souveraineté qu'est-ce que vous appelez
production
que vous regardez une chaîne de
production c'est la chaîne de valeur du
médicament ça commence par les matières
premières donc on a un monde et
principes actifs et ça finit par le
conditionnement secondaire pour la
France ça pourrait finir avec le
conditionnement privé si on avait pour
une certaine série de médicaments
une organisation européenne une
identification européenne et puis
finalement on se débrouille pour avoir
des notices Internet etc etc mais pour
l'instant on en est pas là voilà donc
qu'est-ce que vous regardez dans la
chaîne de valeur c'est à dire que des
séquences des usines comme séquence on
va peut-être pas en avoir 15000 et ça
fait pas tous les principes actifs et
donc la relocalisation pour le
flaconnage c'est très bien c'est très
important mais ça crée pas la
souveraineté
en tout cas ça ne provoque pas la
souveraineté et or ça fait partie des
sujets que vous regardez très près donc
on essaie de comprendre comment vous
comment vous traitez de cette question
là
et puis ma dernière question
porte sur sur l'identification de la
pénurie donc vous dites au moins trois
ruptures par an
vous savez bien que il y a les pénuries
et en réalité
c'est la partie visible de l'iceber
puisque tout le reste c'est ce qu'on
appelle les tensions et les tensions ça
veut dire pour une personne pas pour
voilà une sur 10 ça veut dire une
pénurie c'est à dire que dans les choix
on dégrade la prise en charge
thérapeutique voilà et on limite
finalement les gens qui ont accès à la
lumière à la limitation de disponibilité
du médicament voilà et donc ce sujet-là
est important donc vous traitez la
question des pénuries mais j'allais dire
quand on traite que la question des
pénuries quelque part on se met dans une
situation où on va essayer de rattraper
l'histoire mais en tout cas on l'a
devance pas or vous êtes dans un rôle
d'observation et d'anticipation donc
est-ce que vous regardez ces aspects là
je vous remercie
alors le concernant la liste des de ces
donc je pourrais vous transmettre
effectivement cette liste par écrit
à l'issue je n'ai pas
[Musique]
non plus d'informations sur pourquoi
telser les heures que j'ai citées ont
été choisis en premier c'était un
travail de ce travail amende
identification des médicaments critiques
au sein des heures thérapeutiques et
vraiment un travail qui mené par le
ministère de la Santé avec les sociétés
savantes donc on intervient assez peu
dans ce dans ce domaine là comme je
disais il y a on regarde les médicaments
critiques comprendre le process donc en
fait il y a le ministère de la Santé qui
vous passe commande d'une liste
ils ont et vous vous dites dans dans la
presse donc il y a une liste qui est
arrêtée mais nous on n'a pas fait notre
jeu parce que pour l'instant on serait
pas on sait pas si on va pouvoir faire
quelque chose derrière c'est ça de
comprendre non excusez-moi parce que
vous avez dit on sait pas si on sera en
capacité de relocaliser et peut-être que
va se rendre compte que c'est pas
possible donc j'essaie de comprendre un
peu le process quoi
qui visiblement est muet bien qu'il est
prêté serment mais enfin voilà et ses
propos qu'on est en train de redonner on
essaie de comprendre mais vous êtes
trois mais il y a une voix bon pourquoi
pas donc il y a
dans ce processus c'est donc d'abord
c'est côté ministère de la santé il
regarde quels sont les médicaments
critiques donc un point de vue
thérapeutique en fonction d'air
thérapeutique donc là c'est la partie
amont du processus on intervient assez
peu dedans une fois voilà une fois qu'on
a cette liste de médicaments critique
d'un point de vue thérapeutique on
regarde ceux sur lequel il est
vulnérabilités
sur la chaîne de valeur donc comme je
disais ceux qui sont peu produits en
Europe et donc
voilà donc réponse à ma deuxième
question peut produire en Europe ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'est-ce que la chaîne de
valeur est très vaste certains
médicaments on a 35 étapes voire plus
les vaccins ça peut être 200 à 300 États
à ce stade là la méthodologie la matrice
de d'analyses conditions et en fait
celle qui est issue du rapport Georgie
donc elle elle est un peu enfin c'est
forcément un proxy on comprend pas en
compte 35 étapes de production dans ce
scoring on regarde le où est produit le
principe actif
où est produit et où est produit enfin
où est fait le conditionnement le
produit fini
regardez la matière première du principe
actif
sur la
je me permets de compléter sur la
matière première du principe actif c'est
des éléments qu'on a pas forcément c'est
très complexe en fait comme vous le
savez il y a différentes voies de
synthèse donc les intermédiaires sont
pas forcément les mêmes donc on se base
uniquement sur les deux étapes
principales actives produits finis mais
ensuite bien entendu on regarde au cas
par cas sur chaque médicament l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur et c'est une
vulnérabilité vient de l'intermédiaire
de synthèse qui est fabriqué uniquement
en Chine et dont on est très dépendant
c'est les choses qu'on identifie avec
les industriels et sur lesquels on
cherche à apporter des solutions
peut-être juste pour compléter sur
également sur le enfin ce que j'ai pu
dire hier donc premièrement sur sur le
chiffre de 48 j'ai mentionné le fait
qu'on était actuellement à 48
médicaments mais l'annonce de la fin la
formation de cette liste elle a été
faite par les ministres il y a quelques
mois donc j'ai juste annoncé que en
l'état actuel des travaux nous en étions
à 48 médicaments sur ces trois
thérapeutiques
oui bien sûr mais sur sur le fait que
nous ne savons pas si nous sommes
capables de tout relocaliser en fait
l'enjeu c'est qu'on a enfin nous avons
identifié des médicaments sur lesquels
nous étions très dépendants mais ensuite
savoir si on nous sommes capables de la
relocaliser ça demande un travail avec
les industriels pour voir en fonction de
l'état de notre industrie ce que nous
sommes capables ou non de produire en
France donc c'est un travail qui prend
par nature beaucoup plus de temps et qui
demande une discussion au cas par cas et
donc en effet enfin nous devons discuter
avec la langue industrielle pour savoir
ce sur quoi nous serons capables de
reconstruire les capacités et ce sur
quoi ce sera beaucoup trop cher ou des
capacités européennes seront préférable
ou alors une desertification des
approvisionnements mais donc c'est un
travail qui prend enfin qui prend par
nature un peu plus de temps et sur
lequel au cas par cas nous pouvons nous
rendre compte que sur tel ou telle
molécule la relocalisation s'avère plus
compliquée que sur d'autres
vraiment pour finir sur ce sujet c'est
c'est dommageable qu'il y ait eu les
articles hier ou ce matin parce que du
coup on se focalise là dessus ceci dit
depuis le début de nos auditions cette
fameuse liste de médicaments critiques
elle est elle revient partout que ce
soit au niveau européen et que ça a été
annoncé par le ministre décalé décalé
enfin voilà mais on sait bien qu'on va
pas pouvoir exiger quelque chose de
propre pour 6000 ou 3000 MTM mais que
par contre peut-être que pour 200 on
peut sécuriser quoi donc c'est vrai
qu'on sent bien qu'il y a quelque chose
là
qui est qui est essentiel
ce qu'on essaie de de
comprendre par rapport à ce que vous
dites vous c'est que du coup la liste
qu'on va avoir au final c'est celle des
possibles ou c'est celle des nécessaires
oui mais encore c'est à dire puisque
s'il y a pas de faisabilité
l'approche effectivement de de
de voir quels sont les médicaments sur
lequel il y a un problème sur les
chaînes de valeur ensuite l'action va
prendre en priorité c'est effectivement
et discuter avec industriels pour
relocaliser si la relocalisation est pas
possible effectivement il faudra passer
un plan B ça peut être constitué des
stocks ça peut diversifier les
approfinement etc on se posera la
question au cas par cas de voir sur
chacun des médicaments s'il est possible
de localiser combien ça coûterait est-ce
qu'il y a potentiellement d'autres
actions à mettre en oeuvre qui sont pas
financières pour faciliter la
relocalisation d'un médicament c'est
pour ça que dans la constitution de la
liste des M6 on a aussi discuté avec
l'industrie en amont pour challenger
cette analyse et donc ça nous permet de
définir une approche au cas par cas par
médicament mais comme je disais voilà le
l'option qu'on regarde en premier la
possibilité qu'on regarde en premier
c'est celle de se dire est-ce qu'on peut
relocaliser ce médicament
vous êtes en lien avec l'Agence
européenne du médicament qui constitue
cette cartographie en ce moment et qui a
pour objectif de la produire au niveau
européen au mois de décembre puisque ça
fait partie de de son plan de charge en
matière de gestion de pénurie médicament
a des premiers actes outre la liste
c'est de constituer cette cartographie
on discute effectivement en ce moment
avec Bruxelles pour
essayer d'harmoniser au mieux
effectivement les approches françaises
européennes
elle est pas à Bruxelles l'Agence
européenne du médicament mais donc c'est
en direct avec elle parce que c'est
que vous êtes en discussion avec avec
les mains
surtout avec les services de la
Commission le ministère la santé discute
aussi avec les mains à mon avis donc
nous on discute pas directement avec les
mains
vous allez poser une question aussi sur
la liste des M6 est-ce qu'elle sera
évolutive alors on n'a pas encore défini
la fréquence à laquelle on actualise à
cette liste mais on peut concevoir
effectivement que à partir du moment où
un médicament sera relocalisé en France
ou en Europe par nature il ne sera plus
M6 puisque il n'y aura plus de
vulnérabilité sur sur la chaîne de
valeur donc effectivement même si on
sait pas comment à quelle fréquence avez
évolué elle est prévue cette liste est
bien prévue pour être effectuée
puisqu'elle s'adapte à la réalité
industrielle
est-ce que vous avez des éléments
complémentaires à nous fournir ou nous
enfin fournir sur faire une demande de
compléments écrits
une une remarque outre celle que j'ai
faite quand même un peu le sentiment
malgré la crise
que l'on a vécu là de la covid et puis
et puis le fait qu'il y ait de plus en
plus de médicaments qui sont impactés
par des pénuries
enfin j'entends qu'il faut travailler
cas par cas et c'est tout à fait
nécessaire enfin il y a un minimum un
d'anticipation quand même pour éviter
d'être le dos au mur et la deuxième
chose je reste extrêmement interrogative
sur le le manque de de conditionnalités
que vous que vous donnez aux entreprises
alors peut-être que vos questions que
vos que vos
réponses pardon par écrit seront plus
précises et permettront effectivement de
contredire ce que je dis mais pour
l'instant c'est quand même assez
inquiétant c'est à dire que je veux bien
que l'initiative publique soit
compliquée que
etc etc mais là vous êtes pieds point
liés
à ce qui se passe à l'extérieur et au
bon vouloir des industriels
oui peut-être sur ce dernier point donc
sur la conditionnalité
donc en ce qui concerne le passé donc
cet appel à projet résilience également
un élément contexte c'était un appel à
projet plus large qui couvre pas que le
secteur de la santé donc on était aussi
sur l'agroalimentaire on n'a pas demandé
aux industriels soutenues dans
l'agroalimentaire d'avoir des clauses
approvisionnement en produits
alimentaires en cas de en cas de pénurie
et ça soulève peut-être aussi la
question un peu plus large du bénéfice
enfin de ce qu'on attend d'une aide on
peut aussi considérer qu'une aide
publique en fait elle vient pour
pour
inciter ou favoriser des investissements
industriels en France les industriels
sont parfois en parfum besoin d'un effet
incitatif de la puissance publique pour
pour produire on peut considérer aussi
que cette aide elle a l'emporte des
externalités positives qui sont propres
à elle-même c'est à dire le fait de
pouvoir avoir un projet industriel ou de
R&D en France à des retombées
économiques sur le territoire en termes
d'emploi en termes d'investissement en
termes de réduction des inégalités en
matière sociale environnementale etc
donc on peut aussi très bien considérer
que
le simple fait d'avoir cesertins étaient
positives et le bénéfice direct de
l'aide
écoutez alors on peut on peut se
rassurer à bon compte mais l'expérience
contredit ce que vous êtes en train de
dire voilà donc simplement l'expérience
qu'on a qu'on a vécu fait que et dans
toutes les collectivités ici vous êtes
au Sénat donc c'est la chambre des
collectivités on a on a des mandats
autres et quand il y a des aides des
subventions il y a toujours des
conditions toujours mais on va pas
continuer à polémiquer visiblement on
n'a pas la même analyse
en tout cas je pense qu'il faudra un
scoring de ces affaires là et un
contrôle et un pour utiliser des termes
ou des sistes un feedback de tout ça
parce que les externalités positives
à part d'être listés mériterait quand
même d'être évaluée estimé est-ce que
l'État en a pour son argent et surtout
les Françaises et les Français c'est
quand même un sujet et
voilà c'est le sujet là quelque part
d'autant plus que dans ces affaires là
on se situe pas dans l'innovation
donc la prise de risque elle est comment
dire
elle est non il y a un risque économique
ces projets de réindustrialisation
souvent ils sont associés à des efforts
de rêver qui permettent de produire pour
moins cher et plus verte en Europe donc
c'est il y a souvent un aspect
innovation aussi dedans oui mais il y a
pas la prise de risque sur une nouvelle
molécule je me permets quand même de
voilà
un domaine qu'on commence à connaître un
petit peu et du coup on n'est pas quand
même dans la même
dans la même incertitude que quand on
accompagne quand on prend un risque sur
la recherche
fondamentale vers des brevets sur sur
des traitements innovants surtout en ce
moment on voit bien que donc voilà c'est
ça mériterait quand même de d'avoir un
espèce de process régulier de de
contrôle et de compte-rendus finalement
réguliers un rapport régulier de de ces
aides dans ce domaine là particulier
puisque la pénurie de médicaments mais
en danger la santé et on le sait bien
quand ce sont les anticancéro classique
ancien avéré comme on peut la voir pour
certains types de leucémie aiguës qui
sont en pénurie
assez importante en ce moment
voilà les cancérologues ça se traduit
par retard à la prise en charge
thérapeutique et donc derrière c'est des
effets qui sont palpables quoi
donc donc c'est c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce surjet là sur tous les
sujets de manière générale c'est bien de
de faire des des rapports de contrôle
mais sur celui-là particulièrement il
est nécessaire de l'évaluer parce que le
coût pour la santé c'est un coup aussi
pour pour la population et pour les
Français et les Français et l'État merci
beaucoup